when I was outside on my first spacewalk
I was on the dark side of the world over
the Indian Ocean and I shut off all the
lights in my suit to let my eyes adjust
and as I came south of Australia in the
darkness we drove through the southern
lights and and they were like pouring
underneath my feet and you could see all
the colors of it and I mean I'd seen
aurora from on the surface of the earth
but to be amongst them to actually
directly be part of that interaction
between the Sun and the atmosphere and
the magnetic field all right there
visually like like a prism or a rainbow
or something that was a real reality
check of how it's all related and how
the energy of the Sun and the protection
of the atmosphere and the focus of the
magnetic field all worked together it
really showed me that this is a system
this is a planetary system this goes on
all the time most of the time though we
just don't see it but this is going on
constantly all the time how all those
things work together from orbit you get
that type of perspective you see the
fact that this is a complicated system
that is subject to a lot of influences
that is going on all the time one of the
influences that is affecting earth
itself of course is the beings that are
living on it volcanoes erupting but also
the the plant life and the animal life
and over the last hundred years I mean
gosh where our numbers have rocketed
until 7 billion of us are all
simultaneously exhaling and eating and
turning on our lights in our house and
starting up the engines in our cars
obviously that has an effect on the
planet you know amongst all those other
things happening you can see some of
those effects from space you can see
with your naked eye if you come across
Mexico City or Beijing the pollution is
visible from space it's like a gray ugly
smear on the surface of the world that
is man-made local climate change
if you come across Asia on my very first
flight there was a big Inland Sea the
aral sea still a relatively healthy body
of water back in the early 90s but over
the last 20 years because of
agricultural policies and irrigation
policies the Aral Sea has gone from
being the fourth biggest sea on earth to
being virtually non-existent stride up
and we did it on purpose as a species we
made a conscious decision to allow the
fourth biggest sea in the world to turn
into a little stinking puddle what used
to be a shoreline is now empty sand and
the remains of the fertilizer that were
that were drained into that that's sea
for decades
we're obviously changing the climate at
a global level the key is who is going
to be the person that's going to decide
to change something we can't wait for
some other person to change it they
don't have the imperative to do it
especially if there's something that we
elected if we elected they're just our
representative and the real motivation
comes to each of us individually that's
who has to make the change you can't say
they or him or her or it's it's us or me
or I that has to make the change and
it's it's not going to be perfect and
it's going to have to get a little bit
critical before people are truly going
to feel enough pain or enough
compunction to actually change what
they're doing and things are going to
get worse before they get better but I'm
confident this isn't the end of the
world this is just a problem that we're
facing that is going to change things
but we're going to have to figure out a
way to deal with it
I'm just got enough light yeah I'm
wondering if the Sun is setting on us
there we got it
the Sun is not only setting on us